[Music]
my name is Nick butter I'm an endurance
athlete an ultra runner and motivational
speaker January the 6th 2018 I leave the
UK on an 18-month expedition to set the
world record for running the marathon in
every country in the world
that's 196 marathons one marathon in
each of the 196 countries all right so
it's now the 5 o'clock on the 6th of
January 2018 the trip starts here and
nervous excited
let's see what the next few weeks brings
[Music]
five
they 220 a 3187 156 206 225 267 320 or
345 369 375 400 428 575
I'm doing this because my friend is
sadly dying kevin was diagnosed with
terminal prostate cancer and was given
two years to live
keV said to me don't wait for a
diagnosis get out there and do something
nice to finally meet you man yeah you
too thank you for for making the trek
out here no no it's all right I mean who
wouldn't well here's the thing I was
thinking I was I was thinking about you
this morning and part of the inspiration
for this whole adventure is this
encounter this friendship that you
struck up with this guy Kevin you know
and you know this this mantra that kind
of repeats in your head that loops in
your head about the fact that life is
short and life is precious and you
didn't want to look back in old age and
have regrets about stones unturned and
here we are two days from you know Kobe
crashing and you know nine people
perishing in a helicopter accident
literally about Cleveland yeah very
close by like a mile and a half that
close as that as the crow flies like
it's literally right over the hill over
here you know in the wake of that and
the sadness and you know the reflection
on a life very well lived is a global
conversation about the preciousness of
life and how short it is and how how
fragile it is such a shame and the same
for keV really that someone has to die
or be told they're dying in order for
the conversation to start you know yeah
hopefully through a bit of the running
that I've done maybe we'll keep talking
about it you know yeah so
congratulations thank you you just
completed this whole thing in November
right it's still very fresh this yeah
two years of being out there and the
many years leading up to it of
preparation and logistics like it's just
I can't even wrap my head around what
you've accomplished and it's a it's a
feat that has come up a couple times on
this podcast because I know it's
something that Dean Karnazes has always
wanted to do and the last time he was on
the shows like come on man what are you
doing and then it was like Nick's out
there doing it I think he were just
about to complete it at that point and
so they just spoken to him I did years
ago in LA in in London yeah oh yeah What
did he say and he said he said he said
toric tell rich that I about down to you
and I said I said it really should be
the other way and we swapped and I bound
but he yeah he's you know he's a legend
and he will do it I know he will right
and it'll smash it it's just I know how
long it takes to plan a effect we did it
but it is a bodge job you know when Dean
does it it won't be quite I don't think
that anybody could do something like
that without there being just you know
countless things that come up unforeseen
obstacles and cataclysms that throw you
off course I mean the it's just too you
know enormous of an undertaking for
something like that not to happen yeah
I'm just I'm just pleased we got to the
end I cannot tell you how many times
we've genuinely believed it wasn't going
to happen you know it wasn't a case of
RNA will be all right we'll just throw
some money at it or we'll just throw
some people I don't you know every
possible option you have which gets you
through most things aha we we just we
just came so unstuck so quickly yeah and
then it was just this kind of snowball
effect of things going wrong and then
the multiplying of not having enough
money not having enough time and then
you know six weeks from the end my had
the first of many phone calls from my
dad who is a legend and has managed to
do everything for me on this journey in
terms of flight so he was responsible
for took the job I think I pushed the
job onto him really or for booking all
of my flights and to getting me from A
and B and C and D and then all the way
through and he caught me and said we
can't do it you know this was six weeks
from the end of the trip you said we can
undo it and I we were angry we were
crying we were you know we've come this
far and I was just thinking how am i and
and it went on for a few more weeks of
saying we can't do it despite the many
years leading up to the undertaking of
all the logistical preparation and all
the you know I can't imagine how many
phone calls with bureaucratic agencies
about getting visas and
missions and all the like and you think
you've got it all sorted and stuff just
happens right yeah but I I imagine that
before we left when we got to the start
line as you would with most races or
events you'd prep to the point that
you're ready mm-hmm but it was only not
that right we got to the start lining we
thought well we're probably okay for a
good few weeks you know and we had as
many flights as we could booked and we
knew what we wanted to do but we really
had so much up in the air you know we
didn't know how we really get in certain
countries we didn't yeah it was just
hope you couldn't get that sorted out
way in advance like figuring out how you
know the the visas and the permit I mean
I know it's tricky there are certain
countries where you know they're just
going to say no or you know it's going
to be close to impossible to get in
there and the problem is is really
volatile so you know even if changes we
could which is it isn't possible to do
all in one go at the beginning right
even if we could do that mustard mustard
say it won't change you know and the
amount of times we've had oh ya know
that visa will be fine for years you
know that was one the list of green it
was a bit it was living he was one of
the places that we thought we wouldn't
have a problem and then we did and that
was right because it's only when
political skirmish or something like
that happens
politics violence protests flight
cancellations airlines going bust right
you name it yeah you don't have room for
error when you're trying to do I mean
let's just break it down you're trying
to do essentially two to three marathons
a week into three countries basically to
stay on pace yeah so we we said we've
gotta aim for three countries a week
every week knowing that we were going to
have slip-ups and so you know sometimes
I was doing five a week because we were
making up time yeah and sometimes we
were doing one because I couldn't get
off of an island for example right yeah
yeah and and you left the trickiest
countries it seemed like until the very
end the Middle East right yeah that was
I would love to say that was by design
and when I actually had a bit of a view
that I wanted to leave some of the
dangerous ones towards the end because
if I was going to get kidnapped or
killed or locked up at least I've seen a
lot of the world before that and
seriously and I thought well you know I
don't want to go and do these ones and
take them off and have the relief to
then you know something happen but also
it wasn't a case that
we we just couldn't get access to those
places at the right time and and had we
got access and something gone wrong then
he would have screwed up the rest of the
flights along the line and and that
would have had huge financial
implications so we've had to call on one
part and kind of just just wanting to
you know see the world before anything
happened so Syria Afghanistan Iran
Lebanon Israel I would imagine all of
those were super tricky especially you
you kind of have to leave Israel and
until almost the end right because if
you go to Israel then you can't go to
Lebanon Yeah right they're not gonna let
you in you're on the yeah on the money
they're exactly that we left it till the
penultimate so final one was in Athens
in Greece obviously home the home of
Marathon and I we went we went there on
the November the 10th and the one before
that was Israel and when I set foot on
Greek soil we still didn't know if they
were gonna be okay with me going or
Israel you know because yeah you think
it's okay you don't know lots of lots of
like are go ask experiences yeah you
know when you're trying to board a
flight or get through customs yeah
you're biting your nails singing are
they gonna let me in yes I would say
very augur s bit slightly less glamorous
and more kind of just being in dirty
clothes not knowing really what time of
day it is and I cannot tell you how many
times I've got to a country and I don't
know which one I'm in that's how quickly
they went you know I was standing at an
immigration booth over and over again
and they say so wherever you flown in
from yeah I can answer them you know
just because I was so exhausted and then
you get by the put in a salary you get
questioned for hours even in countries
that are okay because I've got visas in
my passport yeah don't make me look
particular innocent I you know I
certainly haven't undertaking any
undertaking anything you know as vast
and incomprehensible as you but I have
had some experiences in the Middle East
one in particular trying to get into
Pakistan that was you know it was it was
like you feel like you're in a Jason
Bourne movie like it's very strange like
I remember being greeted before I got
off the plane in Karachi and before I
even got to custom
or baggage I was greeted by two soldiers
who didn't speak English who demanded to
see my passport who just stopped me I
was the only Westerner on the plane
coming in from Dubai and they're like me
basically saying give me your passport
and you're like this is one of those
mutt like is this okay like once they
have my passport
I don't know what's gonna happen they
take me down to customs and there's a
lot of you know sort of bickering in a
language I don't understand and it's
it's super nerve-racking anything what
is going on here and you feel like you
are go yeah you feel good you know you
know like what did I do
I'm just here and then they took me into
a room you know and I'm like well this
could be it you know you don't you just
don't know I mean was all fine and all
of that but I suppose the beauty of
doing so many and so quickly is that you
get that so often that you kind of
become desensitized to I go here we go
again when you've got you know another
ak-47 pointed at you and you haven't got
your passport you know anything oh it's
just it's just a Wednesday but that at
the beginning you know it was terrifying
and then other times I've had people
that you know these have got the weapons
on they have their uniform on they have
their badges their helmets they're
they're looking very intimidating and
they then come over and like a huge
smile lights up and they shake me on the
hand and they know who I am and you just
think like all of my preconceived ideas
of everything that's coming you have no
idea whether it's gonna be brilliant or
scary yeah well certainly I imagine it
completely you know sort of changed your
your view of the world and humanity how
could you you know how could you not be
completely transformed after you know
this experience yeah and everybody
warned me at the beginning you know this
will change how you see things as I
changed how you view the world and and I
thought yeah I understand that but I
didn't understand that it was only when
I finished do I now have this new world
view of everything that's going on and
even to be honest it's just kind of
compounded my belief already when I
started and from from keven's message
about we have this precious time that we
should waste but also there's so many
people that don't have the opportunity
you know whether it's in Britain in the
u.s. in other countries that aren't as
wealthy or affluent people are miss you
know we are lucky we are the lucky ones
and yet we don't do enough with it and
so coming back in 54 countries in Africa
are more or less all of those countries
I've
saw situations which I just didn't
realize existed you know yeah and then
on the other hand which I'm a big
advocate as far as well our planet is in
a really great place compared to how it
has been you know poverty over in the
last 20 years people living below the
poverty line has haft she's just
outstanding in my lifetime the amount of
people but but then you go and travel
anything hmm
I'm a bit torn and so this whole this
whole world of this whole world view has
completely changed me and I've just got
a lot of things on what to-do list now
that I want to do yeah like what ah I
want it so I've started this this this
charity which we were kicking off now
called the 1-6 foundation which is off
the back of the running the world 196
trip and I want to I want to do some
more I want to help in a small ways not
start on a whole new charity and make it
you know there's lots of charities out
there they'll just be able to fund and
support some other people that are doing
good stuff and that is that there's that
thing and then there's also the thing
that I want to inspire other people to
do the same thing you know I want people
to travel I want people to see the world
I want people to have that that view and
I often find that it's it's a lot of
hate and negativity comes from
misunderstanding and if we see the world
and if we experience more cultures or
religions or beliefs then then maybe
that hate will be reduced and so when
I'm visiting schools now for the next
year on my speaking tour and trying to
share this journey I want people to
realize that you know you don't just sit
behind a computer and live your world
through your tiny phone in your hand
like let's go and do something else yeah
I mean you know it's very easy to just
descend into pessimism and despair if
you're scrolling and looking at the news
and thinking you know we're on the verge
of an apocalypse and nobody's talking
talking to each other
yeah productive way and we're seeing the
breakdown of Western civilization
unfolding right before our very eyes and
and yet there is an indelible truth that
that you know that we are in so many
ways like this is the best time to be
alive yeah yeah and there are so many
great things to celebrate and and beauty
in the world and and you know to be able
to develop a deeper reservoir of
compassion for Humanity by virtue of
that
tactile you know one-on-one experience
that I'm sure you had a zillion times
over the course of the last couple of
years I mean you can't put a price tag
on that and no so it's almost your
responsibility to to share that yeah I
feel the same and and you know I went
into it knowing that people said oh what
if you know what if you spend all your
money and what if you spend all this
time doing it and then you don't make it
and my view was your banker friends yeah
yeah and basically from the pub oh yeah
yeah you get a risk it you know risk
everything but the beauty is is that you
know when you do something that you love
and that it doesn't matter you know if
nobody buys my book if nobody wants to
watch a documentary if nobody cares
about what I'm saying afterwards I still
had a great time in the process it's not
like I've done something that I was
earning money and didn't care about you
know it's I'm using money and it's given
me this incredible world view that I
can't properly articulate yet so I feel
incredibly lucky but I'm also kind of
impatient to tell everybody else to do
something similar right well let's take
it back to the beginning so grew up in
the UK yep Dorset Dorset Dorset yes
active kid skier right first yeah yeah
so yeah I mean I was doing I think might
like most kids I lived out in the
country in the middle of nowhere you
have to do sport because there isn't
anything else to do
my friends lived all over the place and
though it was either cycling 1015 miles
to get to school or to my friends and
then started running they didn't really
think anything of it it was just a means
of transport and and then I got into
skiing I was in there in the under-19s
snow sports England team did lots of
bits of racing did some instructing but
then I had the voice of my my dad on my
shoulder saying get a real trying to get
out of it yeah come on you've got to
earn some money one day and he was right
because you know ski careers are very
short yeah you know you you you kind of
outdated very quickly and if you're the
best and I wasn't and so I've got a real
job finance banking selling my soul in
London yeah in London to be fair they
were based all over the places you know
and multiple jobs but yeah
London jobs and and I yeah I I enjoyed
it because it was any money and I was
living the life where you buy new shoes
and jackets and you think that's what
you need
be doing and then you look back anything
on my work what was I doing
how long did you do that for it was
seven years oh wow it's longer than I
thought
too long yeah much too long it was it
was a big chunk of you know my life and
and you know I don't want to as much as
I I have damn it in my mind it still
owed me money and it allowed me to do
things but if I could tell my kids my
future kids my unborn kids at the moment
to do something it wouldn't be to do
something that you don't enjoy for money
you know go and do something that you
enjoy and if if you enjoy it enough you
do it well then maybe the money will
come right please pendulums tend to
swing back and forth though like the
kids the kids of people like like you
and me then they go they go into
investment banking nothing this like
hippie you know it's all love kind of
stuff like I need to make some cash it's
so so true so true be interesting to see
how that plays out you know our best
intentions are often foiled oh yeah
maybe yeah you can you completely right
that's gone through my mind but all I
can do is hope and guide a little bit
but maybe that will happen and it will
happen you know I still had that and I'm
still in this point now so you're young
so so you're but you're you're doing the
banking thing and that whole lifestyle
you know hammering checks and and the
whole and the whole thing where does the
where does the itch like at some point I
would suspect and I'm projecting but I
would imagine like you start to get a
little sort of discontent or or you know
a sense of not feeling settled in your
path yeah um I think yeah absolutely
discontent but also not you know you get
you get to the point where you you know
you get a die one day and is this what I
want to be doing until that point you
know I started to think that more and
more and also when you're not sleeping
well enough you're not eating well
enough and you're commuting and you're
in smog and trains and traffic and
you're you realize that your whole life
is based around this job that you don't
particularly enjoy you know I didn't
actively not enjoy it but looking back
it was just it's just not me and if you
asked any of my other colleagues at the
time hey I would tell you it's yes
me yeah well I mean sitting across from
you looking at you hard to imagine you
you know exactly I don't see I was a
lawyer for 20 years yeah I get it no I
you know I can't stand that that life
but I I realized that there was
definitely more and I think I got into
running more and more while I was in
finance because I wanted to have an
escape I think so many people do you
know you're getting to support some
people getting into it for fitness or to
escape or to improve your mental health
and it did and then I realized that I
was ending up turning down opportunities
to go to races because I had to go to
work and then the kind of balance let
you say the pen Djimon pendulum shifted
a little bit right so ultra running at
that time or just 5ks 10ks and that kind
of thing I think I quickly went from
five you know from five to ten to half
to marathon to ultras pretty quickly
because I wasn't very fast I wasn't good
enough marathon runner yeah 253 or
something like that right good memories
yeah no it's not but I know like to turn
around exactly I need to take another 40
minutes if I want to be a good Mariner
no and I I did some did some early
ultras some just hundred K 120 K things
and and I thought okay I can do it and
you know I was finishing in the in the
top three top five regularly and I
wasn't really training you know it's
just working and then driving to a race
and getting out and getting your trains
on and doing it and you finishing okay
and you're thinking hmm maybe I can do
this and I'm not I'm really not a very
good runner still you know I'm not I've
done what 600 and something marathons I
am NOT a good marathon runner I just
enjoy it and all the ultra runners say
that it's true it's true it's because
we're too slow to run marathons quickly
they don't have a fader but it's a big
leap from saying like oh I want to you
know I want to do ultras too
I'm gonna pursue a career or a way of
making a living doing this especially
when you're in you know this white shoe
industry where you're making quite a bit
of money it's not like oh you're a
barista at Starbucks or something like
that you know what I mean it's a there's
risk involved and you know real world
considerations and it's not like yeah
there are the Dean Karnazes out there
and the people who've been able to
to figure out how to do that but it's
not an easy thing yeah yeah you're right
but then but then having yeah you're
right so you say how long were you doing
that finance job for it was the answers
too long you know because for a good
chunk of that 80% of that I was wanting
to escape but I think what led me to
that cliff which I kind of called it the
cliff of adventure in doing what I'm
loved is that Kevin here we talked about
earlier who was my big inspiration he
was just the final shove you know all
the way through my life I'd had little
mini shoves towards the edge and whether
it was you know my my headmaster when I
was in school whether it was a teacher
whether it's a family friend I've had
some really brilliant people around me
that have loved the outdoors and
adventure and it just is kind of going
in slowly and slowly and then you start
to do this and then you have this idea
you know you meet somebody like Kevin
and he says to you he's dying he told
his his liver potentially only 2 years
and prostate cancer yeah terminal
prostate cancer and you have this guy
that is incredibly happy telling you
he's dying and you think well you know
you don't understand I didn't really
didn't understand how this guy was so
happy and so genuinely positive in life
when he was potentially gonna live for
only two years and then it dawned on me
that he realized that life is you know
he's doing everything that he loves in
life is so precious and so that was the
final shove and you know it wasn't a
case of right I'm gonna go and run
around the world it was what can I do to
raise some money for them and then I
worked out that it had to be big enough
to get the attention because I wasn't
well known and so it just kind of
spiraled you know it was what can I do
and then I realized after one short
google has anybody done it and obviously
following Dean he's been threatening to
write and he hadn't yet and so let's
give it a go it's kind of amazing that
no one had ever done it for fine no I
absolutely can't believe it I feel very
really lucky and almost like a thief
like I've stolen it from all right
nobody's like eating at me you feel like
an undeserved ya know wearer of the
crown yeah absolutely because there's so
many great people out there I mean
especially Dean but others as well the
you know me you made it happen yeah
that's the difference I'm proud about
that I'm proud that I'm the first person
to do it and I'm proud that we did it in
it really was a journey of
horrendous lows in her and fantastic
highs and so it was exactly what it
should have been so just so I understand
the timeline you're you're starting to
get into ultra as well you're still
working at the bank right yeah meanwhile
your your your banking ultra and you met
Kevin at marathon - saw right so you're
able to like train and and compete at
marathon to solve while you're still
working this job I was working less than
yeah that was I think that was probably
already like got one foot out the door
one foot yeah my whole soul was out the
door it had been four years but yeah
yeah literally my I was hot I was a
little bit at the door and I was ready
to go for it so the real exit plan is
lining up enough support for this new
crazy harebrained adventure that would
allow you to train and and you know do
this thing and feed yourself basically
yeah you know what a lot of people have
said that to me the training didn't even
go through my mind because I thought
that the hardest thing in that holy they
had two years from meeting Kevin to then
thinking about it and then coming up
with the idea the idea was made and it
was two years from idea to to start line
right and that was mostly planning you
know I turned up in Toronto Canada - 25
degrees C super super cold on day one it
was January the 6th 2018 and I got there
and I realized I hadn't run a marathon
for three and a half months mmm because
the train you like broke your ankle like
you're months before you started right
yeah yeah and and prior to that I mean I
read that I read that like you were
putting in 150 mile weekend's yeah big
you were putting in some pretty that was
epic
you know blocks I didn't realize that it
was too epic at the time because I was
just going for it and I my body was
right and I was really good actually
think I was fitter then than I am the
hell huh just because I was I was
escaping from work and you know I was
constantly running every possible minute
I had right and then that 2 years was
just like on my word we've I've jumped
into this world where I don't know
what's gonna happen I need to make this
I may need to make this trip planned and
logistically possible I know I can run
and then I just forgot to catch up the
running bit and so so the planning the
two years of planning transpired while
you were still working at the bank half
of it yeah see I half of it they were
very good to me and they said have time
and they let me have some unpaid leave
and then I didn't go back right and I
was very honest with them I had some
fantastic you know you have good bosses
you have bad bosses at that time I was
very fortunate a brilliant friend of
mine now called Rossi Rossi Ahmed he um
he he supported me and he believed in
what I was doing and he understood that
there is more to life than work which
isn't isn't that common in that industry
and so he said yeah going going can do
it so by the time you finally cut the
cord and walked out the door for good
you had enough support
lined up at that point and you were well
invested in the preparation phase of all
of this to be able to make it work I I
let I definitely jumped before we had
everything lined up because there had to
be so much I spent a lot of those two
years planning it on my own and then
another friend who I also met in the
desert in the same tent as Kevin a guy
called Jeff who's a really lovely guys
in Everest summit er and he said to me
you know you need to really get some
people in your team you need to pay some
people I said I can't pay people cause
I'm gonna spend a fortune on this trip
and they said no you need to invest in
the support cuz you can't do on your own
and that was my first time I thought hmm
okay I probably should listen to that
and I did and I spent some money and I
employed an assistant to help me work
things out and then skip forward to the
middle of the journey where we had
nineteen people that were working plus
loads of volunteers that were making the
trip happen whether it was psychologist
nutritionist performance manager
security visas and and then we got to
the point that we couldn't afford it
anymore and people started dropping off
in people's lives continued especially
the volunteers you know and so we went
through this whole big cycle of just me
planning it having a little person
involved and then it peaked at a really
big team and then it petered out and I'm
just fortunate that I have some really
great and as you know anything that
happens like this is it's not just me
there's so many people that make it
possible I can't even imagine like
trying to compile the right people to
make these doors swing open it's almost
like you need to hire a specialist or
like a diplomat with relationships that
run deep internationally so that you can
kind of
you know massage who you have to massage
to get these visas to go through you're
like I know you've ended up having to
pay a lot of bribes I'm sure those were
like you know feet on the ground like
you know when you're trying to go
somewhere or something like that but
just the the pure politics of the whole
thing yeah unbelievable the politics was
difficult I had a company so I worked
out that I could go with a visa company
that would get me all of my visas and we
worked out the value and it was
something like 25 thirty thousand pounds
of just just on visas and then we found
this great company called Universal
visas and they said you know what we
want to support you we want to help you
and we'll take all of our fees out of it
and it really helped that's great but
there was such a small unit and and when
you get little wins like that you take
them when you hold on to them and and
Faisal of Mars here they're kind of a
founders of this company they are still
great friends would be now what's that
regularly and they made everything
happen but it was only because they were
working at two o'clock in the morning on
a Sunday went on their day off that it
was possible um and that was the same
for everything I honestly I owe
everything to these people so I I was
very fortunate but in terms of bribes
and they say massaging my way through
all of these but you know when you turn
up a boarder I remember in Chad and I I
didn't have a page free and my passport
and I was getting stamps on like the
inside page and all sorts of stuff and
they said you haven't got any room we're
gonna have to charge you and it was like
$400 for a day's entry when it would
usually be $20 just because you didn't
have I didn't have a patience lie on
page which is rubbish you know that's
crazy
it wouldn't 2019 this is a piece of
paper right he put the money straight in
his pocket you know and and you had to
go through like ten passports right
because you're having to send passports
to different locations to get them
approved for visas and we're waiting on
the return of them while you're also
trying to cross other borders like how
does that work yeah yeah so and now
travel with two and I always traveled
with one and the other one would be home
so there was always two in in the
pipeline and you can have two like they
allow you to have t.i house ports yeah
and even though I think it's I think
it's common over lots of countries a bit
you you have to have a reason for it and
you have to ask and I had a very clear
reason why I needed it
but then you have problems where you
realize that
okay so I've missed a country because I
was ill or because I missed a flight or
we had to redirect for some reason
because of protests and so I've got a
visa in the wrong passport now what do
we do you know and that happened I'd say
close to a hundred times
Wow and it was I have friends and that's
when you have to like make the 2:00 a.m.
phone call to the visa P folder expedite
whatever yeah and some be landing in two
hours yeah yeah exactly and sometimes
they say to me well we can't expedite it
because your passports in France oh you
know or somewhere else oh and they can't
physically do anything cuz I don't have
it so yeah he was a logistical absolute
logistical nightmare passports is one
thing but then you have the flights just
linking up from cont you think it's
obvious to be able to just fly from one
country to the next even if you have to
go around the houses a bit but but it
really isn't easy linking up the 14
Pacific Islands into two and a half
weeks two weeks no one impossible and
when I was speaking to Dean the other
day you know if he's gonna do this
quicker which I believe he will is it's
gonna take some serious I mean you gotta
have to have private loans there isn't a
way to do it much quicker yeah he should
just hire you yeah you're the one person
on the planet pixel in it I've told
about experience with it run with him
over the next two days now I'm here but
I've loved I really would love to see
him do it because I quite like to be an
outsider looking at the trip so I don't
have this dress that's very spirited of
you were there ever countries where you
had to kind of skirt the law and just
sneak in and get away with it I mean I
know I had about charlie angle on the
show a couple times and he's told
stories about you know hit their epic
you know trans-sahara
run that they did and I think they got
to one border I can't remember what
country it was and they just weren't get
a lot of man mm-hmm and I can't remember
how they solved that but it was another
kind of nail-biter visa situation yeah
lots of those occasions and so we had
two or three visas that were refused
multiple times so that was Iran Yemen
and Syria off the top of my head and
they were places where you don't just
sneak your way in easily you know if you
say oh well which border do you wanna
cross that's illegally
in Syria isn't the one you'd be pick and
so we did manage to do it all lawfully
but there were occasions where so for
Iran I went to Kish Island which is part
of Iran but I felt so intimidated there
because you were told you can't come
your visa was refused multiple times and
it was only approved through the visa
guys I had no idea how we made it work
and I don't know if I'm if I arrived and
is actually valid but I had a moment
going through Yemen from Amman drove
through the night from Amman to get to
the Yemeni border and this guy my driver
he was lovely but very dodgy that's all
I can describe him as he was just
appeared and seemed very dodgy and I was
a bit nervous it got to the border at
2:00 in the morning this was about five
five countries from the end this was so
close to finishing and I realized as we
were crossing the border with all of
these military personnel 20-plus armed
people are surrounding the car that he
was smuggling goods into the country and
using me as a mule basically and he said
to me you know just put these under your
seat and just sit on these and don't
don't tell them and here's me spending
four or five years to get to this point
of planning and work and effort and I
thought how is this happened and we were
there for a couple of hours they quizzed
us we had everything out of the car
there was lots of raised voices and
fortunately they let us through he I
think but I have no idea what they were
saying but by the looks of things he
paid them yeah
that's terrifying it is yeah because you
could have just ended up in some yeah
prison somewhere the key thrown away the
government is I don't know if they'd
come and get me that yeah there's yeah
you're diplomatically you would be in a
world of hurt yeah
yeah and and and I had that feeling a
few times I was locked in an airport in
Central African Republic for a while
because I didn't have the right
paperwork with me and I didn't have any
money to pay my way through I'd used all
of my bribe money up you know I'll
travel with thousands of dollars just to
use as bribes when I can because you
have to especially going over land
borders in Africa isn't it it almost
feels not like a bribe it just feels
like the dumb thing is almost there's a
tax like killing a chair for one is that
going exactly that
yeah actually and I was tipping heavily
Bram and I ran out of money and and I
just had to wait until the following
morning
tell that to for them to let me out of
this Airport Wow
and I say Airport is just a shed but
yeah so it must have been I mean I think
people who don't know any better look at
what you did and it's all about like how
did you run all these marathons but like
that's like the easy part you know it's
just like oh it's a relief all I have to
do today is like run 26 miles like I
don't have to worry about all these oh
yeah yeah I remember you know remember
having those those days in my diary you
know I look at my diary in the morning
and it's either flight day or run day
more or less every now and then you get
some more time off flight day or one day
I went it's a run day it's just great
you know yes there's some times when you
you're terrified to go and run because
you don't know whether you Guinea
attacks or you know it's mugged and all
sorts of stuff happened but you get to
that point where you run day is the best
bit I love running I'm a runner but then
you know you'd have to get on a plane or
you don't you know I've had some
connections which were eight different
planes just to get to another country
and then you have to arrive and it's two
o'clock in the morning you have to run
and the running bit is just the reset if
without the running I think I'd gone
crazy you know and with the you know
logistical problems that were
continually arising and flights getting
cancelled on all of that I mean every
day lost to some unforeseen circumstance
pushes you off your schedule and makes
it more difficult down the line to kind
of you know complete this thing to
family yeah absolutely so I got a lot of
room for error there was no room I mean
at the beginning we were a bit naive
because we thought yeah okay we've we've
built we built in about 4 buffer periods
of about 10 days throughout the trip and
we thought okay we've got a little bit
of time if things go wrong but then we
it dawned on us that we'd used that time
far quicker than we then we planned that
buffer time had gone before we'd got six
more bonus points or done all the bonus
points of you and this is over just so
people understand this is over like what
624 days or something like 75 670 674
days who in in that period of time you
only have 10 days of wiggle room
Yeah right or whole thing capsizes
absolutely yeah yeah and and and you
know that that's the scary thing you
have you have so little wriggle room and
we had a moment where I was bitten by a
dog in Tunisia one of my first African
countries Chinese he has relatively
affluent and compared to the other
African countries these five dogs on the
beach I was running with a friend of
mine who came out to support and he and
I were running along this Beach and
these dogs just came in and bit me
uh-huh and I thought it's okay I've got
my rabies job of only two and a half
miles from the end I just ran lots of
blood pointing down my leg and I got to
finish and I thought that's fine
carry on but I didn't realize that I
needed to have top-ups
for my rabies in subsequent weeks and
where I was gonna be they didn't have
the rabies vaccine readily available and
so it meant rejigging everything and
that was just you know and since then
following that bite I was terrified to
get bitten again not because of injury
but because of ruining the trip right
well dogs were a big problem
yeah they were bright in one particular
Island of note the Marshall Islands
absolutely yes so I did lots of so I
call them like the micro States so
you've got most of the Pacific Islands a
tiny in terms of where the land is
there's lots of land kind of semi in the
water semi semi out to the water and
you've got vatican obviously Jonah's
country in the world 82 laps I did have
some pizza square in the Vatican did you
get like was there some with that what
was their weird permissions like okay
here's where you just run the perimeter
inside the wall yeah
so I tell you what I could have that
could have come unstuck really really
badly quite early on so Europe was my
second phase of the journey and third
phase of the journey and there was a
security guard who came to me when I was
eight miles in and said you can't run
here and it was only by pure coincidence
that this security guard was heavily
into kungfu and my friend who was
filming for me at the time happened to
be very heavily into kungfu and they
once again sport winning they shared
their sport of sporting moments and he
said you know what i'm not gonna tell
anybody just get it done Wow and how did
kung fu even come up I know I know and
and because I I you know in those
situations you saying you do whatever
you need to to convince them and I said
you know I
ran away this is fine I've done it in
all these countries please help and you
ask the question like you a runner he
was sport and it's later and we got
chatting I tried to be as friendly as I
possibly could because you have to be
and it turned out and I've still got his
email address he was a brilliant bloke
because he he could have said no yeah
and and we didn't have all the right
permissions that we needed which I
thought we had but we didn't and I
couldn't he said go to the go to the
office go to the visa office which is
just around the corner but I couldn't
leave because I was eight miles in and
if I'd left I would have gone out out of
the country yeah and so he just he was
brilliant sick coming back to those
countries very very small countries at
140 laps in Jamaica because of some some
gang violence in in Kingston and then
like you said the dogs proved very very
difficult everywhere but especially in
the Pacific Islands and I ended up doing
335 laps of a car park in one of the
most beautiful places in the world which
turned out to be rather ugly
there's just wild dogs everywhere they
just run after you
yeah so all you need is one you know nip
on the Achilles and you're toast exactly
that exactly that it's the it's the
Achilles I was most worried about you
know if you get bitten in the wrong
place and you can kind of soldier on and
patch it up but if its nipping something
that physically stops you from moving
and running pace then you screwed um and
I had 20 dogs I actually think it was
more than 20 but call it 20 dogs big
dogs very aggressive if they have a
diabetes crisis in the whole of the
island because people don't have go
outside and exercise these dogs because
of it because the dogs and I arrived in
my hotel and they gave me my room key
and a stick and they said if you go
around the corner to a shop you need to
take your stick and they didn't know I
was trying to run a marathon yeah that's
yeah like how would you have known that
I know me Oh Dino take your stick or a
Taser and then there was a country where
you had to run on a like a landing strip
yes to blue one of the most
hard-to-reach countries in the world
because they have I think there's a
couple of flights a week and there isn't
any space on the island
other than the runway and so everybody
lives on the beach which is rocky and
you
you simply can't run there but what to
my amazement not only was I allowed to
run on the runway a live runway because
they knew when the flights were coming
and there wasn't gonna be one when I was
there but the whole community of this
island used the runway as a hub of sport
you know everybody comes out it was the
most unbelievable sight thousands of
people on this and it was the whole
country you know literally everybody
from the country uses this runway and
I've got great videos and photos of
people playing volleyball and and
cricket and football hundreds of
different games on this huge couple of
mile stretch runway and so I was very
pleased to do my home I don't think that
many people so did you get a bunch of
people there who ran with you yeah so as
they I mean you know you start off you
do first up and down and they kind of
look at you like you're a bit nuts and
then once you've done your 15th or 16th
time and they realized that something's
going on and and yeah everywhere that
everywhere was like that people came out
which country surprised you the most oh
um I think I would say nearly all of the
countries surprised me my preconceived
ideas of the countries when nearly all
the time completely wrong and that's
because of the media it's because of my
my brain reading stuff and taking it as
read taking it as that's what it is
there were some there were some really
lovely countries which I didn't expect
so Sierra Leone was a really fond
favorite of the whole journey the people
there are poor um their health and their
healthcare system is is incredibly poor
and yet everybody there was smiling and
we'd have people you know women passing
me water bottles saying water is life
and they have nothing to give and yet
they give you their water you know and
that just that provides so I think it's
very difficult to say which surprised me
the most you know going to places like
Turkmenistan and North Korea which are
incredibly controlled but you got the
whitewashed propaganda tour in North
Korea right yes like they they're just
with you the whole time and their show
you what they want you to see in the
whole thing yeah I think you have to be
incredibly lucky to not get that
propaganda at all but what I did see was
more or less what I was expecting it was
incredibly clean you know there's lots
of little aspects to stuff that you
think I wasn't expecting that or you
know how they all queue in single file
in silence in the in
in the underground and and little things
like that but it was more on a bigger
scale than the things that surprised me
the most is how the correlation between
people that are so lovely and have
nothing you know and then I end up
spending that you hear time and time
again from anyone and everyone who's
traveled to those types of places they
come back very very struck by that by
that truth and yet and I've said this
before on the podcast we get home and we
you know we we forget or we reset it's
so easy to reset it and I really try
hard not to but I mean I have you know
you you get up and you buy stuff you go
online you get into your rhythm again
and it's really hard to buck that trend
unless you I believe unless you move
away or you immerse yourself in it but
there is there is ways to do that and I
think it's just it's just be it be more
in touch with it so see it more and read
about it more and don't necessarily you
know there's the amount of negativity on
the news and sadness on the news from
stuff going on and yes we need to know
about that stuff but there's also some
brilliant things going on in the world
that I wish people could pay attention
to there should be a positive news
channel right I agree with that but then
conversely coming up I'm doing my bad
conversely you know there's certain
areas of the world that don't get enough
attention for you know what's happening
there I mean Haiti stands out as one
such place right like and I know you had
an experience there
yeah Haiti Haiti country number four for
me on the trip it was certainly my first
experience of of poverty and obviously
the earthquake there that killed and
made a lot of people homeless and
orphans and the violence there really
struck me it was heavily armed people on
the streets they were approaching me
when I was running and it was only
because I had a guy that was driving
behind me a snail's pace when I was
running in humidity to to help me with
the water that I realized that there
isn't there isn't enough shed you know
you be in places and I'll see something
on the news about some horrendous attack
and I'll call home and say oh don't
worry I'm safe and they'll say well you
know we haven't he hasn't made it to our
news and it's thousands of people that
have been killed or something in either
a natural disaster or or by human hands
and I feel
yeah III you're right there's just not
enough of the right media yeah how many
of the marathons were sort of sanctioned
races versus you just creating your own
course yeah
difficult to say because a lot of the
most of them were my own course but most
of those own courses were turned into
races by people that were supporting me
there yeah exactly so I would turn up
and not have a resolver but it was
pre-planned enough that the people there
knew what was going on oh yeah had set
something up for you yeah so my plan my
default plan is to get to the hotel
look at a map roughly know where I'm
gonna run run the distance get some
witnesses along the way job done mm-hmm
but more often than not as a trip went
on as it as the awareness grew I was
arriving and then met by people and they
say oh we've got this route for you
these are the water stations do you need
any other food this is the media what a
good call it's amazing yeah you know and
it happened to whatever the place I felt
like you know I was having my own
personal running water own personal runs
everywhere I went yeah yeah yeah and for
purposes of legitimizing the world
record aspect of this for guinness like
there's all kinds of rigmarole that get
baked into that right like you got to
have multiple gps trackers and
thicknesses and things like that like i
know it's the whole thing it's a pain
it's a real pain and they're sticklers
they are stickers and i guess they
should be yeah on one hand I agree with
it on the other hand there is a certain
it's frustrating me because it's kind of
trying to fit a you know a square box
into a round hole kind of thing there
isn't the rules that apply for a big
two-year multi trip easily but I suppose
the base I had 11 pages of rules by the
way you know that's how detailed they
wanted my and I agree and luckily we
followed them and it's been a pain and
I've had lots of people helping me to
make sure we've got those everything
they needed but you know I wore two
different brands of watch so two
different kind of GPS systems I had a
GPS tracker that was just on me that
wasn't a running launch and then we had
to get witnesses during the run some of
them were hotel stuff it's difficult you
know when you run in I don't know in a
Portuguese speaking African country
about 20 months before I finished the
trip sign this affidavit have no idea
what this
so we've had to get lots of backups you
know people I've met in airports or on
the plane I said can I just get your
email just in case you know just in case
have they signed off on it now so what
is that vetting process
yeah it's long it's really long so we
need to we need to log the log book we
need to submit an official logbook with
all of the data in but my logbook is a
little bit difficult because along with
all of those witnesses and GPS data we
have all the photos and videos 400,000
photos and 20,000 video clips to show
because that's all metadata and it
proves where it was and it helps my
cause and so we're we're in the process
of sending the hard drive a physical
hard drive with everything on that they
can go through and yeah and decide
whether a fit so in addition to the
visas and you know making these flights
and all of the travel you know
logistical nightmares that were
continually plaguing you on top of all
of this you know you're traveling in
most of these places alone like more up
more often than not right this is you
yep and you're taking responsibility for
making sure that you have the witnesses
and that you have you know your watches
are all charged and all of that and
you're trying to film this thing for a
documentary right you're documenting it
for a project beyond that like so just
the mental headspace like okay are the
SD SD cards wiped and like where's all
the footage and how are you logging that
like in I mean yeah yeah I mean you've I
can't imagine you know staying on top of
all of that on top of everything else
yeah you hit gives me goose bumps I hear
me sitting and you talk about that
because I was incredibly proud that I've
managed to do that but I honestly don't
know how it happened you know the amount
of stuff the watches you mentioned what
she's being charged when you're staying
in some crazy country and there you know
if you have the right adapter and all
that kind of thing right yeah the amount
plug yeah yeah and also even when I'm in
places where there is perfect
electricity perfect adapters you know
I'll get so shattered and I'll have a
shower and I'll lie on the lie on the
bed to go to sleep and I'll fall asleep
and I wake up at 3 in the morning
thinking I haven't charged my watches
because if I don't charge them
I can't run and if I can't run then
we're gonna have to replan it so even
little things like that were a stress
fortunately I mean I had my my brilliant
assistant and a guy called vet on who
organized a hell of a lot for me and was
constantly on my case but it was there
you know when you go away with people
and you decide whether you want to go
left or right or whether you want to do
something or not do something having
that sense check with somebody else was
difficult not to have it you should I be
running down this street now is it safe
you know should I haven't got any
security in the center of Caracas in
Venezuela where is famous for kidnaps
should I actually go out or should I
wait you know and having that sense
checkers is difficult
yeah like you say the documentary
filming everything as well a great
friend of mine called mark Beaumont so I
could around the world has the world
record for the recycling well he's he
gave me some great advice before he left
and he said if you if you're filming it
you've got to film all of the stuff that
you don't want to film mmm you know and
as when you're tired and you just like I
just want to rhyme like I don't need the
extra hassle like having to document
this and I don't feel like it right yeah
and even to the point that I was
actively aware of how Fertitta was by
the fact that my brain didn't want to
lift my arm to take a photo you know
when you're at the end of a very very
long run and your whole body is to pull
it and any slight movement is a waste of
energy
mentally my body was okay but mentally
being able to go all right here I
finished and do a video and try and
convey what you're really feeling when
actually I'm thinking about right okay I
need to get some food now and you know
all of this stuff that goes on and food
food was this whole big other aspect
which which went I mean I think it was
take what you can get take what you can
get and eat a lot always ask for seconds
on the planes even if you don't like it
you know that kind of thing yeah yeah
how many flights total 456 Wow
including the flight home yeah and to
put it into perspective we with we
thought we would do 220 so that gives
you an idea of tell bald young the
planning the ideation to the actuality
yeah yeah
it's just so many things went wrong and
I believe we we planned it as well as we
could have with the time that we had in
the budget and everything but even if
you had all the money in the world all
the time in the world to plan this
things go wrong hmm and that was why we
had so many flights we have 450 old
flights 120
visas nine passports on my tenth now
yeah it was
how was Lebanon yeah Lebanon was when I
ran there in Beirut as the official
Lebanon marathon though Iran that was
fine
Iran along the coast and it was
beautiful huh but I've done that Beirut
Mara I've been here twice so yeah
familiar with it along the corniche
there yes gorgeous beautiful yeah it's
beautiful and I like done the food is
great as well and I I then had to go
back to Lebanon to get into Syria mmm
and crossing there was a load of protest
quite recently only a few months ago and
crossing by ground into Syria yeah a
cross exactly leaving Lebanon leaving
Beirut to go over into Damascus and the
a couple of days before no the the day
before I was due to arrive I had a call
from my dad saying that the tour agency
that's supposed to be taking you tour
agency is you know it's not this big
tour company it's just one man on the
ground yeah said that their driver the
driver that he'd hired to take another
group of people to the border the
previous day had been shot and killed
there was I know there had been a real
all these protests going on and the
problem was the Lebanese plated cars
traveling towards the Syrian border or
the other way around and so we had to be
careful too and I switched cars halfway
through the journey in order to not have
that danger and I remember you know I
thought I was when I did that journey
we've made the decision that we're here
we don't have any other time let's just
go for it I'll get my head down let's
hope for the best had another driver
obviously because the driver was killed
before and they advised me not to do it
and I let's just get it done and I
remember asking the driver if I could
stop we didn't to be very good English
at all and I said can I stop go for a
week yeah I need to go for we and he
said no here we and he was racing
through and only by pure luck and that
we made it and we switched into the
Syrian plated vehicle and and went
through the border and then how is Syria
Syria was a surprise the center of
Damascus is beautiful and actually much
less rundown than I was expecting people
are lovely and by pure fluke again this
happened so many times where I would be
in a position where things would happen
I was running around these
Stadium in Damascus because it was safe
very hot and there's lots of cars and so
it was a good easy way to do the
marathon and I had witnesses as well so
it was a win-win and I ran in Damascus
in the stadium and then a few miles into
the run I was joined by the Under 19's
national Syrian female football team Wow
and they were coming to train and they
saw me run and they were like yeah let's
do a few miles with you what an amazing
thing I was 20 25 odd people that were
they were all training in their pristine
running kit and it's not something that
you think of as Syria you know and it's
the gaze back those preconceived ideas
of you know people expected me to be
running in a war zone with bombs going
off all around me right right
do you think that the experience would
have been different if you were American
yes yeah I just briefly said that to
Dean as well yeah in the amount of I'm
very fortunate to be born British and
not half of those political blockers
though that said you know we've con
alike colonized a lot of the world and
we've had some you know we've had some
lots of frowns and looks to me but it's
a little bit different I think it's more
hostile yeah yeah you know I would
imagine what about Pakistan were you
able to run out to earth yeah there when
I was there I was in you know they were
like you can't go outside and and my
host was training for a marathon and
lived there was a Pakistani national and
he didn't train outside or if he said he
would occasionally run outdoors but he
could never go back to the same spot
like at the similar time of day like he
had to mix it up yeah because of his toe
turns yeah I was told that advice thing
if I'm doing it don't don't post my
route don't tell people where I'm gonna
be just in case there's lots of lots of
countries like that that it goes back to
this people say how can you sum up the
whole journey in one word and I see
people and this network of people that
had that made it possible was exactly
why I've really enjoyed Pakistan I
mentioned my old boss the good boss
razzing he was Pakistani born in
Pakistan and he had a really great
friend that used to go to university
with in Lahore guy called Kabir and he
got on the phone to his friend and said
Nick's coming to Islamabad will you help
and he did and I arrived at the airport
he picked me up
he'd gave me at all he went for some
dinner
and unfortunately it was absolutely
torrential rain and so I was running in
about a foot of water which was that I
was running down a central reservation
of a four-lane highway in Islamabad
because it was the only dry place to run
dryish place to run but in terms of
danger I had Kabir tell me where to be
inside knowledge and it's without all of
these people I can tell you it would not
happen you know money cannot buy you
those connections yes you can get people
to to to be there at the right time and
to pick you up and to have a security
guard with you but actually it's the
inside knowledge that made all the
difference yeah I would imagine there
were probably options in certain you
know dicey countries to do the marathon
on like a British military base yeah
right
yeah did you ever do that or did you off
- no I want to be in communities I
didn't do any in British military bases
I did in Afghanistan Iran in the UN
compound in Kabul because we were due to
have a five armored vehicle ethical up
into the mountains which was unheard of
but they'd approved it and then it was
retracted because there was a blast and
a few people killed an attack the day
before I arrived again and so incredibly
sad there's lots of gunfire in the
evenings when I was there but it was one
of those places that I was in this UN
compound and we ran we ran around all
over the place there was a brilliant
ultra runners as part of the the UN
staff and they supported me and we ran
with them a helmet and a bulletproof
vest for some of it and I didn't want to
leave you know you turn up to these
places terrified and then you make so
many great connections you don't want to
leave and say yeah there was a few of
the few compound runs like in Jamaica I
ran around the High Commissioners
compound because there was 67 people
murdered the weekend I was there through
gang violence in Kingston right where I
was and you know they weren't gonna kill
me but I might have been in the wrong
place at the wrong time yeah and so
there's lots of things like that which
you don't plan you know go to Jamaica
you think of beaches and rum and
cocktails and
but stuff like this happens all over the
place and so you have to be a little bit
wary what did the kit look like like
what was the bag you know that you were
hauling around about change as you
figured things out yes I suspect he
started with more than you needed and
then as you got your footing that's that
was at that it was a piece of luggage
got a little bit smaller absolutely it
was a bit like a bell curve actually I
started with a big-ish pack a rucksack I
was traveling around the world take a
rucksack that makes sense but everything
was just difficult to get into it I had
far too many things skip ahead to the
end and I was traveling with a tiny tiny
bag with like one pair of pants one pair
of socks and just washing like showering
in my clothes and washing them and as I
went on that's a good thing about
running yeah yes once our shorts you're
wearing your shoes already yeah no I
tell you that and I'm still a still have
them with me right now cuz I'm going for
a run later today the pair of shorts
that I wore all the way through my kit
sponsor which I'm wearing do sport live
they they gave me some shorts and I wore
them every single run and it has a bite
mark out of the back whereas bitten by
the dog and I still wear that to this
day so you absolutely gotta frame those
yeah I'm getting frayed then we might
auction them or something I just a
little browner soap and you're good yeah
they're they're pretty disgusting I
think I think the frame would I think
the crane would were and they're really
there son you know what the the
waistband they're black and as they go
down because it's been so Sun Sun
bleached they're basically close to
whitening right so yeah my kit where my
kid went up and down but I also had a
bit of a problem with them souvenirs
people used to give me brilliant
sunlight medals with my faces on
trophies made by brilliant sculptors and
all sorts of stuff I didn't have
anywhere to put it and so I ended up
having actually travelling with a
souvenir bag because I didn't want to
have to say no to opportunity to take
something yeah and you want to have that
stuff it's cool what about the camera
equipment I mean was this this iPhone or
GoPro or like how are you documenting it
every bit of camera equipment has ever
been made not quite and I traveled with
a lot I travel with some decent lenses
for some I love my photography and we're
releasing this photography book and it's
just a hobby but I believe I'm OK at it
and I'm passionate about it and so I
travelled with a lot of photography
lenses
for taking photos for like DSLRs like
full-blown full-blown like three heavy
load yeah right big lenses you're
running with that stuff too sometimes if
I had a so frequently I'd have a car or
a motorbike or a cyclist that would
support me and so they would have it
right car behind me and then if I see
something I want to take a picture of
this a group of kids or something you
know I take the picture but sometimes I
wore my backpack in and I ran Osprey
gave me these really great running
backpacks which were quite bit bigger
than the other ones that someone wanted
so they do fit the cameras but then
GoPros I had three GoPros I had my drone
which was confiscated many many yeah all
my batteries I had I think they had my
drone in Syria
no I didn't I didn't disagree I don't
think I know close but it was it was
confiscated a few times Cuba most places
in Africa don't like it Haiti was
another one and yeah I heard with lots
of it and and it was a lot of it was
stolen actually in China and I didn't
realize it been stolen but my bag when
it went through the airport they decided
that I wasn't allowed the camera
equipment and so put a nice letter in my
bag it all in Chinese which I couldn't
read which I assumed says we've taken
your stuff and I never got that box did
you did you have footage in there that
you lost them or just the equipment very
careful with the footage the footage was
always backed up immediate right so yeah
you got it you got to finish the
marathon get to the airport backup the
footage right my blogs
tell people anything make sure that the
the own but you did a great job of
chronicling the thing in real time on
Instagram with beautiful photographs and
yeah thanks I think so my my Instagram
and I'll plug it's Nick butter run Nick
butter run I posted it because there's
no point you can't do it after the fact
you know I can't spend the following two
years doing it but it was difficult and
people would often mail me or email me
or message being saying are you alive we
haven't heard from you in a day yeah I
know I mean the Central Africa I'm in
the Congo like I haven't got easy Wi-Fi
and yeah connectivity where is another
another big thing trying to check in
with people and my Sat phone being
broken sometimes and
able to actually write my blogs write
everything on Instagram and remember it
because I was writing notes as well hand
notes for my book because there's stuff
that you want to remember that isn't you
know I can't fit in a in a small small
space in an intro post so it's overall
you know you get an idea of the scale of
a trip it's um it was the most amazing
feeling to finish but I I feel like I
want to go back it's almost like a big
wreck II you know I want to go back and
see more of each place there's a cool
like sizzle reel film on your website
that you know basically gives you an
idea it's kind of very you know quick
cuts yeah all these different places it
reminds me a lot of Casey neistat's do
more videos very it's very much in that
style of like it's so hectic and chaotic
and there's so you're just being
bombarded with the stimulus of so many
different cultures very oh yeah I know
we like those videos I was very
fortunate spark media put out together
they came to me before the trip and said
you've got to do a documentary I'm will
help and I said well I can't put any
money towards the documentary night now
because we're spending everything on and
everything else and they said don't
worry you know we'll just we'll just
help you put it together and they are
now producing the final expansion right
yeah how many hours of footage did you
come up we have 20,000 we have I think
there's 18 terabytes 20,000 video clips
so so tough at it because you know it
can't be 196 episodes you know like how
do you craft a cohesive narrative out of
such an epic journey without it being
repetitive yeah you know yeah exactly I
think a lot of people would say well I
ran here then I got on a plane then I
ran here you know it fit to me it wasn't
like that you know it was it's basically
going from one problem to the next and
just just just articulating in a
relatively linear narrative of this is
what happened but the way that we're
doing it it's a parallel narrative we
have lots of interviews with my family
and friends and team and that's
interspersed throughout the throughout
the documentary but it's the same when
writing the book you know my book and
I'm plug it as well because um it's on
Amazon's log away it's on Amazon it's
called running the world
coming out later this year but there's
no it didn't seem to be a specific
release date no need to finish it it
leads me into I
written almost the word-count for this
book and I'm only in chapter 2 you know
how can I cut stuff out it's it's yeah I
want I want people to see the whole
journey is it's really difficult I think
you your first pass needs to be
overwritten you know get it all down and
then you have this big piece of clay
that you can chip away at you know and
and it's so fresh I mean you just finish
this thing to get it I think it's
important imperative for you to get it
all down on paper as soon as possible
and then you have something to work with
yeah you're absolutely right and I'm
spending the next few days running
writing running writing until I go home
into the more stuff it's um
yeah I love it I'm a very very
privileged position to be in to be able
to moan about having to write difficult
directly opener wow that's cool on a
very practical level like how you know
how is the process of you know lining up
all of this sponsor support and kind of
you know making sure that you're serving
them as well I mean this is our
relationships right yeah Kiki like
they're not just giving you money you
have to be you know a good ambassador
for these brands and I mean you have
like 46 bands or something like yeah
that's supporting you right yeah I would
imagine it would have been it seems to
me it would have been a lot easier you
just have like one huge company comes in
Visa Nike whatever it is writing a huge
check and you just you're you know you
have one company but you're having to
work with tons to kind of cobble this
whole thing together if you can write to
to Branson for me that would be great no
we did my Richard yeah well you've done
it already now just back pay me though
no it's um you're right having that many
sponsors is difficult but fortunately
there's very very few of them that have
any formal commitments and they're
people that have come out the woodwork
and said look we want to help you we
don't expect much but what you can give
we'll be grateful for and I think on
paper you say 46 sponsors we've got no I
think it's 50 just under 50 and I think
a lot of the outside world would see oh
it's just a load of money that people
would be giving you I spend ninety I'd
say let's try and get this right eighty
five eighty two percent of the trip that
kind of number I was paid by me and my
family yeah the rest of it you know you
a lovely lovely brand would give me some
socks right
that's a great great but it doesn't
doesn't know anything else and I need
socks but it may be
I need 500 bucks because I don't have a
page on my feet you know my password to
get stamped yeah exactly that and when
you're wasting you know getting into
Bhutan cost us 1,400 dollars just
because it's a it's a difficult track
yeah I need an invite so you have to
basically pay for it and so it's
actually funding the trip has to be in
the top two or the top three of the
hardest thing to do and I sold virtually
everything my parents and my family gave
up a lot of money loaned me a lot of
money and all those suits yeah I
actually did yeah there's a lot of a lot
of shirts I went to charity shops as
well because I've got so many shirts the
irony being is I now need a shirt to
wear to wear when I do my theater talk
no I yeah absolutely right I stripped my
life back I allow live in a van I live
in a van and I travel around doing my
speaking to all over the world with just
trying to share the journey and it I
wouldn't change it for the world and had
I had hundreds of millions of pounds to
spend the trip wouldn't have been the
same and I wouldn't have felt so
invested and so pressured and all of the
feelings were amplified by having
everything on the line you know being
told I wasn't going to do this six weeks
from the end after having everything in
my basket you know I hadn't not let
anything else it's that motivation you
people say so what gets you out of bed
in the morning when it gets tough that's
one of them yeah you know I think I read
that the total cost of the endeavor was
in excess of like five hundred thousand
pounds yeah more like that yeah I would
think it would be more than that it was
it was yeah but I mean it's did we
haven't actually done the final numbers
yet because there's a lot of stuff that
we're still paying it I would say it was
it was close to more close to a million
but that kind of money you know there's
great friends of the family that I
haven't seen for years who just put
their hand in their pocket said we'll
give you will give you a few grand and
that makes all the difference at the
right time
well if it makes you feel better you
know a decent documentary budget is
about a million yeah so maybe that was
the budget of the documentary that
you're made
yeah well yeah it's nicely a few other
things happen anyway that's a very good
point there's a very good way of looking
right come on spark it's all on safari
right now we've got lots of good
connections with the document I'm very
privileged and I I feel like I just want
to go and and physically I cannot I
can't tell you how thankful I am of
people I almost get emotional thinking
about it the amount of people that have
come out just you know a lovely lady
called Rowena she was listening to the
radio before I started and she lived in
Spain's British lived in Spain and she
said come and stay with me I stayed with
her put me up in a beautiful home in
Barcelona she then drove me to to other
countries because she wanted to help
and it's that selflessness of people
from all over the world that made the
journey and I I just want to encourage
everybody I speak to in this upcoming
tour to to help so like to realize that
your people around you are everything
that make the world good without people
the world would be beautiful but it
wouldn't be as fun what are some oh I'm
een you you just kind of said it but you
know the the takeaways and the lessons
yeah I think the takeaways a never try
and remove those preconceived ideas from
countries more and I really mean it more
like ninety five percent at the time I
was away it wasn't exactly how it was
portrayed you know in all of the whether
it was a guidebook or whether it was a
Travel Magazine or you know you compiled
all of this stuff of how you believe a
country is going to be and unless you
visited it it's it's it's not the same
so now what is it like when you turn on
international news and you see some
report from someplace that you've been
well first thing I do is text my mates
there and say you okay more than than
know that's the real reason and then I
get the response back of you it's fine
that's not actually as bad as they're
saying or it is bad you know and there's
when I see at CES CNN for example lots
of big disasters from all over the world
or BBC world news as well there's a lot
of stuff that needs to be talked about
and I believe that by focusing on some
of the negative stuff it actually
creates positive stuff because people
then come and help but I wish there
could be the follow-up stories of this
is now what's happened in the in the
wake of a disaster or the wake of
something happening because it because
people need to see that as well so
I guess the other big thing is coming
right back to the beginning message that
keV taught me which is not waiting for
not waiting for something to happen in
your life to kick you up the backside to
do something you have an opportunity to
do it now
and whether you're ten years old or 80
years old you probably have something
that you want to do and you have an
opportunity to do it even if you like me
can't afford it wasn't fit enough really
and so just just go for it and Kevin you
know who you met what year was it that
you did marathon the sobs 15 16 15 15
was diagnosed with basic I mean
basically a life sentence right and now
it's five years later yeah five forty
days something like that yeah join you
in Athens yeah it was incredibly moving
we had a lot of Tears during that run
and had some laughs and some really
lovely chats so keV keV was 49 when he
was diagnosed given terminal prostate
cancer given as little as two years to
live
and he dry he describes it at the moment
as drug roulette so he's basically
taking his drugs and one day they'll
stop working and maybe there'll be
another drug that works and maybe they
won't and it's that day that comes that
we don't want to happen you know when
when he'll drop off a cliff but and you
know in his meds will stop working but
five years on he's still with us and he
still will die from cancer he was
absolutely riddled with it and I just
wished that we could get the message out
there so I suppose this is a big a big
message of mine that I'm gonna probably
be preaching you out the rest of my life
is that if you are a man and you're over
40 years old and you haven't gone and
got your prostate checked you have to do
it because you could have prostate
cancer with no symptoms and you could be
literally dying any day that's the
reality if you don't get checked and you
catch it late the chances of you dying a
huge if you catch it early the chances
of you living a huge and so and also if
you're not a man or you're not over 40
the chances are you know somebody who is
and so that's the most common form of
cancer for men right yeah biggest is
actually overtaking breast cancer now so
it's the biggest yeah yeah so it's it's
overtaking breast cancer and breast
cancers obviously had a lot of public
awareness and funding and I just feel
like it's now time to turn our heads and
look at this cancer there's now killing
a lot
and twelve just over 12,000 men die from
prostate cancer in the UK alone that's
every 45 minutes so you you use this
adventure to also raise funds for
prostate cancer UK right yes we on the
Just Giving page we'll have to check it
I think we're about 125 but I know we've
got a substantial offline that's gone in
so I believe it's just over the 200
thousand pound mark we wanted to raise
250 and I think we will hopefully with
when the book and the documentary comes
out and with my so that's like it's
always ongoing and I won't stop until I
know that that target is in the bank you
know because there's no reason why we
can't do that it's just it just takes
everybody that's listening to this and
everybody that's listening to the things
I'm going to say in the future just to a
dollar fifty cents a pound whatever it
is just small amount really makes a
difference and that money that we're
raising is specifically going towards a
national screening program and so that
means that men can get access to free
and easy checks without having to go
through this whole ordeal and and I hope
will then have enough money to combat
the stigma attached to prostate cancer
and the fact that people don't want to
talk about it because it's embarrassing
which it shouldn't be really I didn't
know exactly yeah because people men
especially don't want to talk about it
because it voters rabona that's the
reality and it shouldn't it shouldn't be
the case because it's killing people and
so I'm convinced that if it was if it
involved a different part of your body
they wouldn't be killing as one
relatable so you got this speaking tour
yeah coming up has that already started
or you're on the cusp of that yeah I'm
so Dean just the other day speaking in
international running show in the UK so
it's kind of started but it's ramping up
properly starting in March and it's like
a full boy I looked at the schedule like
it's a little a lot of dates
oh yeah UK all over the UK and we're now
starting to do some in the US as well
and what I've got planned in the future
will bring me to North America and so
I'm hoping that if people enjoy
hopefully people enjoy what I'm saying
and we'll take something from it in the
UK and then I can I can then do more in
the US and what's that what's the
message when you get up in front of kids
or schools or these groups
theaters yeah that I think the message
is to a there's a big message of
resilience in this whole journey right
you know overcoming the stuff that you
think you can't do when you when you get
out of bed in the morning and it's
raining and you think oh I can't go
everyone it's cold you know yes you can
like there's other stories behind it but
the overarching messages of time so I
preached about this number of twenty
nine thousand seven hundred and forty
seven which is the average amount of
days a British person will live for
twenty nine seven four seven is the
magic number and I want people to
realize that that number is going down
every single day and we have an
opportunity to live to live our life
right now in in the UK alone we spend on
average nine years of our life watching
TV and we spend 90% of our life indoors
and so I'm basically standing up and
preaching about the fact that like yes
okay you need to earn money to feed your
kids and pay your mortgage but your to
have an opportunity and a responsibility
to enjoy and to live your life as
passionately as you can with the stuff
that you love because otherwise it's
going to be too late you know you get to
your deathbed and not have done what you
wanted to do so when I look at what
you've done one thing that strikes me is
is that you just basically made this
decision to do this like you you became
a runner later in life yeah it wasn't
like you were out winning races winning
bad water and marathon to saw like you
were you're you're an enthusiast and
obviously you have a certain amount of
talent and dedication because it's hard
to run these all these ultras but the
thing is like it's not like you were a
name inning and and you just took it
upon yourself to do this thing that
nobody else had ever done and you
figured it out yeah that's I think it
seems like people oh he was a banker and
he was that you know I was like I maybe
he had a million dollar bonus that he
just paid for this thing but that's not
the case at all no not the case at all
not the case at all and you're right I'm
not a fantastic runner I like you said
ultra runners say that but I'm really
not I'm not even that fit not even that
healthy you know I literally just wanted
to go and live by what keV said is to
enjoy it and to travel and to run and
and I want going to continue to run
because it helps in my mind with my
everything that I have in my life so
it's running
I described as just very much my mode of
transport and it happens to be a cheap
was a cheap and easy way of getting
around until you decided to run around
the world of course right and I think
what's funny as I was reading some of
the media on you and and and it seemed
like journalists were were shocked that
you still like to run like oh this is
like like you're like I want to get back
to running now that people are like what
bizarre isn't it I don't really
understand what a question I get is so
what are you gonna do next well I'm
obviously gonna I'm gonna run like I'm
not just gonna stop but at the same time
I get the point of I've run so much now
do you want to stop there and tell you
what I am NOT missing which is getting
on and off planes yeah well having that
long snaking queue in airports to get to
immigration but no running is not you
like yourself is some it's it's great
for if you love it you carry on doing it
obviously is there a bit of a coming
down from such a you know huge
experience I haven't experienced it yet
I think things have been kind of
niggling me in the background like stuff
that I I've missed that I didn't realize
I was missing like meeting new people
all the time yeah you know I was meeting
new people and making friends every
couple of days and then having this
great relationship with them and then
having a chat with them on whatsapp for
the following weeks and now I I'm very
much in the zone of yeah okay I'm still
meeting people in theatres and I'm you
know talking to new people but it's it's
not as intense and it was that was quite
a special two-year bubble of my life but
I think the lot of people did say oh you
could have to prepare yourself when you
come back because it's gonna be a this
but I've just filled it I've just filled
this gap with being busy and writing the
books and in the document documentary
out and doing the tour and I think once
that stuff starts to die down and I
finished the book and I've compiled with
the photos for the photo book and I've
witnessed the documentary come and go
and it starts to fade a little bit there
maybe but other stuff will take it yeah
I think that's healthy you know there's
a I know a lot of people who they do
some really super crazy thing and then
they feel like they just have to keep
upping the ante or doing something
crazier
you know it's that's an addict mentality
because it's like chasing the dragon
right like you did you've done this
incredible thing and much like I would
imagine you know a soldier returning
from a deployment like there's an
adjustment period
because you've gone from a very extreme
situation not to compare you know
running marathons to being in battle but
the idea of being in in in something
that's that's not of the normal life
that is very heightened and intense to
then being sort of sitting in the
countryside and having to adjust to that
right and there's this this wanderlust
or this itch like you know I need that
dopamine rush again and I think people
get into trouble with that but to the
extent that you can kind of leverage the
experience that you've had and the kind
of platform that you've created for
yourself to then take that whatever that
energy is and pour it into being of
service to other people I think you'll
find great fulfillment in that yeah I
hope so and what I what I've got next is
still running and it's I just slowed
everything down and we're gonna go the
the plan is to do something similar but
to enjoy it more not focus on a record
or time and to basically write more take
more photos and and really yeah I
suppose just immerse myself and what I'm
doing and what I hope to do is to run go
and run set another record just because
it's not been done by running a marathon
in all of the national parks in North
America that's cool because exactly he's
cool he's beautiful and I've got rather
than doing three a week the schedule
that we've roughly planned and I've been
thinking about it for a while even
during the last trip was it's about ten
days every ten days I'll do a run and
all that are then breaking it down to do
some school talks and to do some other
corporate work but also just travel
around in the van getting a puppy in
three days time by the way and say the
puppy will start to run with me and and
then get go over to the u.s. in January
2021 and start trekking across to all
the national parks tick them off over
500 days and then go up to Canada and do
another 500 days to tick off all of the
other national poll
one border crossing easy easy and I hope
I'm not gonna have it to pay any bribes
to get into Canada either you never know
I was kind of living in the headspace of
Ricky gates over the last couple days
because he's the most recent episode
that I just put up and and have spent
quite a bit of time thinking about his
cross country you know unsupported run
across America
yeah which has parallels to what you've
done but but which is also a very
different animal because he he's
somebody who you know whether it's
running every Street in San Francisco or
running across America like these are
ultra endurance events but they were
really about taking your time and and
connecting deeply with your community
and your natural environment and yours
is different in the sense that you're
popping in you're running these
marathons you're having it you know a
valuable experience with the people and
the landscape when you're there but then
you're out right it's very rapid yeah
rapid fire too rapid too rapid and and
certainly for anybody that does this
kind of thing or the same thing again in
the future whether it's Dean or
otherwise you I wanted more time
everywhere and you add one one day to
every country there's another nine
months you know that's the that's the
kind of things if you can't add another
day but slowing things down 596 extra
days just exactly it's it's it's intense
and I what I'm doing in the future is
just slower and I want to take time to
look around and enjoy what I have and I
also I'm looking to get into a bit of
learning about the environment because
of you know our big problem in the West
is the environment despite the fact of
all the other problems going on in the
world I want to just learn a bit about
it and and start to use the trip over
those 1,000 days to to learn and to
hopefully share what I then have come
back and see you in a few years time and
say well this is what I now know because
I know virtually I don't know nothing
about the environment because how to do
lots of offsetting projects for my trip
to make our whole journey carbon neutral
and so this next thing I'm trying is is
to learn a bit to share the journey of
this trip as well and hopefully get
other people into into sport let's talk
about the carbon offset
think that's interesting because there
is there is this thing like oh it's very
self-indulgent you took 445 flights and
God knows how many you know car rides
etc like how do you offset I mean that's
a massive for a carbon footprint offset
yeah
so we I was trying to find companies
that were going to be able to help me
offset and I think the standard standard
one that everybody jumps to is when you
offsets in carbon emissions you plant a
tree you know that's the that's the
obvious go-to but there are many many
other ways to do that and using the
carbon credits model which is so through
this company called natural capital
partners they very kindly replied to my
one of many many emails and said yeah
we'd love to help you and they sponsored
my offset by giving me four projects in
which we would do various different
environment to work so to use an example
Guatemala which was also one of my
favorite countries as a company they're
called eco filtro and they do water
filtration and they also create stoves
which require less wood and therefore
the people that are cooking on these
stoves then have to use less wood and
then the smoke is less and so they get
little less and it's also cutting down
less trees for aliens and so what this
company doesn't they you know they're
very very big company for the lots of
multinationals all over the world
and they said we've put all of your it
even asked me about my diet you know
what kind of what kind of diet I had and
how many planes would be taking and how
many and they gave me this certificate
with which was offsetting 45 tons of
carbon emissions and we're currently an
email discussion about upping that just
to make sure we're completely covered
with everything so 45 tons was offset
which was co2 equivalent and that means
that all of these we had four projects
around the world this one in Guatemala
was one of them and not only does it
help the environment but it helps the
communities of people in in in in
country mmm-hmm so it I don't know if
it's a perfect system but I think it's a
much better way than just planting trees
that's for sure yeah one of the places
of in the world that I that I know so
little about that it's embarrassing is
Africa
hmmm I think it's the same for a lot of
people yeah I believe I know a bit now
but what I have seen I like him I
suppose this is him it may sound silly I
don't know but I like in Africa similar
to the u.s. in the sense that all 50
states and 54 countries in Africa and
they're very much governed differently
different laws different rules different
attitudes different races different
religions it's just the Africa currently
is less well-off but if you were to read
books like a great book called fact
fulness about how the kind of
environment no and the culture of wealth
is is shifting to Asia and Africa
you'll start to see that Africa is
booming it will boom it's not a case of
oh no they can never be a civilized
society Africa is a beautiful but B has
so much potential and so in terms of the
the the climate and everything that's
going on there I had it I think it was
an average temperature of 44 degrees C
in those 54 countries it was hot yeah
what is that like that's over a hundred
phone yeah absolutely scorching and some
places you know deserts don't have don't
have rain for very long periods of time
and then you you learn about all of this
and then you go to somewhere like the
Pacific Islands which were actually
directly under threat from rising sea
levels I wish I also learn which you
know it's also about the the saltwater
membrane in these islands and how the
water is rising and ruining that so
there's all sorts of elements but I tell
you what if I could tell anybody to go
and visit any continent and spend some
time it would be in places like Sierra
Leone and Togo and the Congo where where
people live very very differently what
about the Antarctica and the Arctic
Circle yeah good point could mention it
well I definitely didn't need to do any
running in the North Pole because there
isn't any land it's just it's just
frozen water but in Antarctica
technically co-owned by seven different
countries and so it's not technically a
country didn't need to do it but it's
one of the seven continents right now
I've got to do it and so I was talking
with a few friends recently about what I
could do and I'd love to run in in
the pols something substantial but then
I have the conflicting interest of the
climate you know and the environment and
should I be
should I be traipsing through these
places that are delicate and maybe
should be more protected over there yeah
it's an interesting thought experiment
because in terms of offset like if you
can create a you know an adequate amount
of awareness that creates some kind of
action in the wake of it does it become
you know a rational thing to do yeah and
your guess is as good as mine and how
you know until you've done it and is it
worth taking the risk and I mean as a as
a tourist as a human of the planet I'd
love to see both the polls and to
properly witness them and do a brilliant
expedition and yes I would love to plan
them but I don't want to we're in a
quite a delicate balance with with the
climate so I don't know what how I'll
feel about that on the learning you know
I've talked about this learning period
over the next few years when I do this
next trip I might completely change my
mind and go completely green in
different way everything how's the diet
we can start there it's done now the
conversation about that right now my
diet and your diet are probably the
opposite no I love and I will do you get
closer and closer to to the likes of
your diet uh-huh I have I'll leave you
with a couple books yeah please do
please do I know I'm I'd love to
throughout this whole trip at these two
years I've actually thought about being
vegan through it through the trip and
I'm so glad I didn't because I think I
would have starved because yes there's
obviously that you're not gonna start
with it would it would added you know
much complexity to it although I think
you know in a lot of you know
less-developed parts of the world you
know they you know a lot of vegan food
is popper food it's you know it's rice
and beans
yes grains and things like that like you
know especially you know I've traveled
all over the Middle East like that's
like the best vegan food oh yeah places
where you think oh it's gonna be so hard
and it's not hard at all no I'm not I
don't know enough I don't know enough as
I should to make kind of informed
decisions and there's also the occasion
only many many times when you arrive in
a country at 2:00 in the morning
and the only thing next door to you is a
chicken house or in a fast fast food
place and if I go anywhere else then I'm
at risk of either getting into trouble
or getting lost or getting attacked or
whatever and so I think I've made a lot
of excuses what I shouldn't do that but
maybe by the time I see you next you
might you're my new project yeah please
rip okay well here I was like looking at
some of the stats on your run so on 22
of the marathons you had food poisoning
on four of them you had kidney
infections yeah you did a hundred and
one marathons on an empty stomach I mean
yeah 22 marathons with food poisoning
horrible the amount of days I woke up
and literally would just crawl out of
bed to the bathroom to then vomit and
then get my gear because of the water -
something you ate in a strange land yeah
yeah a combination of everything I think
it was a knock-on effect of not having
enough water so for example in Iran I
didn't have water for 24 miles it was 40
plus degrees and I was urinating blood
by the end yeah as peeing blood and I'd
had that several times but in Bangladesh
the humidity was huge and had I so I had
a kidney infection and food poisoning in
in Bangladesh 40 odd degrees and I was
literally throwing up every single mile
and you just you know you think I'm
gonna just give this was that the
hardest marathon that one and q8 or
djibouti djibouti in Africa was
scorchingly halls of the heat yeah and
you know I was I was trying to cover up
as well to kind of be respectful in
these places and you just end up
absolutely roasting I remember
sheltering in a place in Djibouti which
was a tiny tiny shed over of a
restaurant and the aircon unit they had
there which was a huge aircon unit was
cooling the room to 32 degrees C it was
it was so so hot even indoors and so
those temperatures about it yeah lots
and lots of food poisoning and it got
very much like a so I was used to it I
took lots of supplements to try and help
like probiotics to help my guts and
stuff but you know when you're out on a
run and you need to drink from a tap in
somebody's garden
thirsty it's I would imagine you got a
lot of shots too before you yeah every
cent every literally everything you can
have that took I think it was three
months to get ever lying and then I was
more or less done and I had to have a
couple of backups the following year in
Indy year two of the trip that was fine
I felt a bit ill and I had I think it
was two hundred and something days on
antimalarials which makes me feel rough
anyway in in certain Muslim countries
running in shorts no bueno
yes right and there was lots of places
where I would turn up and assume that
that was the case and then I would ask
in reception whether it was fine and
they'd kind of give me the look as if to
say you idiot right of course
of course you can wear whatever you want
and then in other places it was the
opposite you know where I assumed it
would be okay and it wasn't but then did
that cause problems uh yeah I'd had a um
somebody threw a a water bottle at me
out of the window
which was full and it hit me and it hurt
but it wasn't damaged me but they they
were honking one country was a I
remember I'm afraid no it was Central
Africa I also then I was hit by a car
and I broke my elbow you know in central
Africa and I believe that was semi on
purpose it was just their wing mirror
but it hit me so hard
mm-hmm that my elbow broke but I was in
a cast like how did that go down no so I
I went to see a doctor like that was in
the in one of the embassies and they
said yeah we well if you want me to
Rexroat then we'll have to take a few
days out and I said wolf we're gonna
have the day so we don't know and then I
went back on one of my passport pickups
so one of my many times when I've had to
go back and exchange passports back to
the UK the UK for like 12 hours and I
went and got my yeah exactly and I got
my my over looked at soon yeah and so
yeah there was those times when I did
have to think about the the religion was
a really great eye-opener I tell you
what even if you do this whole trip just
to learn about religion but I was I
happen to be in Saudi Arabia in
jeddah the day of Eid where everyone
gathers in Mecca just the day just the
night before and the families which were
having these huge gatherings along the
coast it was just so beautiful to see
and I came very very very kind of almost
fell in love with the with a different
range of religions that we have in the
world and so again it's another classic
example yeah religions are seen as as
war makers and bad sometimes when yes
they are but there's also the other side
of the coin
I've been running in Jeddah have you
yeah I ran along the water the corniche
yes yes over the bridge and along and
you've got the a couple of mosques yeah
there's a couple more right on the coast
line or along there yeah it's quite
something yeah we're running in a day on
night day Daniel yeah and I ran in
shorts and that was a place where I got
back and they said you probably
shouldn't have done that yeah
I ran in yeah and I ran in shorts in
Riyadh also and was told afterwards that
that was not a good yeah I think that's
slightly and it was just it was
ignorance really I just didn't I just
didn't know but I but that's the same
knife been in places where I thought it
was absolutely fine or where I've been
running around places during prayer time
and anywhere else it would have been
fine but at the moment I was in the
wrong place at the wrong time and I was
disrespecting people by not giving them
space when you know you make those you
make those mistakes right so so now that
you're home and you flip on the news and
it's brexit and it's Trump you know
insanity and all of that like what is
the lens through which you kind of
process all of that given the
worldliness you know of your adventure
yeah yeah worldliness I definitely do
feel worldly I definitely also feel like
I'm not as worldly as I want to be still
because in all those places have just
discussed there's so much more to be
learned and the enemy there for a day
yeah exactly be there for it I mean you
still run 26 miles it's still a lot lot
to see but actually to take into
people's religions and what they do at
mealtimes and all that sort of stuff so
when I when I look at the news my lens
of this whole new worldview that I have
it's one of sadness on one part because
I want there to be more positivity and
to show the great things that I've
experienced but there
on the other hand complete elation and
joy how lucky I feel to have seen
everything and then of course you have
breaks it and Trump and all of the
squabbling the squabbling over things
that you know I wish we could just spend
a little bit of time just give us ten
minutes of the news a day talking about
the problems that are happening in the
Congo or in Sierra Leone or you know and
and oh yeah there's there's there's
there's lots of ways to look at it it's
frustration to be honest you might most
of what I see as frustration now because
I want to do more I want to be able to
shake people and rattle them and go how
are you moaning about brexit again or
moaning about your commute you know the
world has well it takes some crazy event
to rejigger people's you know sense of
priorities and and that's you know to
bring it back to Kobe Bryant I mean
that's kind of the you know everything
kind of stopped on Sunday when that
happened it was so shocking and and and
absolutely Surrey it was a incredibly
foggy morning here like you couldn't the
visibility was almost nothing so there
was it and that's sort of unusual and it
was just as bizarre there was a weird
heaviness where everything just stopped
for a minute and the whole world like
bore witness to this thing that had
happened and it allowed us to kind of
connect with what's truly important and
I just Nessa the question yeah the
question that arises is why can't we
make that more you know top of mind in
our daily decision-making and how we
navigate the world and I hope and you
say that you know what do people want to
get out of my talks when I speak to the
minutes that you know it's it's it's not
having something in your life or going
to somebody's funeral or seeing
something bad happen on the news for you
to wake up and realize that every moment
that we have of every day is is is so
privileged
especially us in the Western world and
there's privilege society we have so
much that we can give and we can do even
if it's just you know spending more time
with your family or saying that to your
loved ones that you love them more or
going and doing that pottery course or
that singing lesson or whatever it is
that you're putting off you know that
tomorrow may not happen and luckily for
Kobe he's he's had this incredible life
where he's done a lot but I guarantee
there's also things there that he hadn't
done you
that he'd wanted to do yeah no I think
that there were a lot of things that he
you know he had a lot of things that he
was working on and wanted to you know
express in his life and then you know
his daughter and the you know the other
people that were on that it's just it's
unbelievable you know not to end on that
note I do want to know what your banker
buddies think like now that you're back
are you still connected with the people
that used to work with like you know
them how does that how does that go
hello to my friends its I mean I'm what
I'm turning up to see them now when I'm
living in a van so that's that's
different right like the weird guy down
by the river now exactly exactly there
it's to be fair I think some of them
look at it in an Envy in a little way
not just the traveling bit but just the
change that I had the I had the jump but
also a lot of them still think I'm crazy
you know turning her turning turning her
back on on money and and I mean it
wasn't it's not extreme but it's it's
there's there's there's both sides of
the coin they definitely think about my
true friends they know that it was
always in me to do it and so there's
some of them many of them a great friend
of mine Andy who I used to work with he
came in 219 with me 19 countries 19
marathons and he was just coming out for
the weekend and started in Brazil and we
did that's cool we ran in Chernobyl
together also stuff yeah
family's good yeah fun is good my
parents bless them
my dad shook my hand at the end when we
had a little final closing thing in in
Athens and and said never again he
honestly they have been so great and and
my brother throughout that my brother is
younger than me and he's a nurse and he
took six months out of his job and life
to convert this van that I'm now living
in so when I returned home I school I
didn't have to go back into the into
that life and so I could kind of
seamlessly progressed so yeah the amount
of people I and I said I've said this a
few times I've had just over 2,000 new
contacts in my phone from all over the
world and so when when there's holidays
all over the place or when there's
religious occasions happening in the
world I get these messages wishing right
you know from everywhere but it's gotta
be
wait who's this guy like what country
did I meet him in like yeah I've saved
people's names with the country now
photograph like you know I know it would
be hard to keep all that straight oh
yeah it's but it's great for context
because of now being able to help other
people that want to travel and so on my
website I have you know it's set up a
whole consulting business around boots
yeah I'm trying like a fixer I'm exactly
I'm a I'm a fixer that can't remember
where I was
though I've got a lot of great people
that can help so I mean along with that
this next focus for me is this this year
is the speaking to I'm also doing a few
little mini runs really good at
circumnavigate Iceland we're gonna run
around it's a mini run mini run thousand
miles a couple of weeks we're trying to
trying to do that that's gonna be
beautiful difficult more enduring
certainly on the body now there's a
cycling race that goes around this yeah
yeah I mean there's a beautiful Thomas
Road all the way around right around the
country and then I'm gathering a few
people with with the brand that's been
supporting me for four years do sport
live they are giving me the reins to
create a team to take out to Malawi and
we got to run
the length of Malawi oh just for fun
just to gather some team that have to
have this this whole ethos of this brand
is exactly what I breathe which is be
set free similar to yourself just being
outdoors and live this world so I'm
putting a team together and other than
that it's it's speaking to all time so
if anybody wants me to speak anywhere
then let me know because I want to share
the journey and I think I mean I it's
all very well doing this over a
conversation but the amount of photos
and videos that kind of illustrate the
dodgy moments kind of paint it yeah
better than I can
well good man it's all good I thank you
I'm so grateful for you having me on
yeah fantastic I mean you know I can't
congratulate you enough I just can't
even wrap my head around what you've
accomplished it's it's really quite
something super inspiring and I can't
wait to see you get out in the world and
and and share this message I think it's
super important so my hat's off to you
and and I am here as a resource enough
service so if you ever need anything
from me yeah I'd love to help you out
Thank You Man oh I'm very grateful and
you've you know what you're doing I
think
many people underestimate the power of
good you're doing so I'm grateful thanks
release sitting in my house talking to
Tom people like yeah I know and it makes
a whole lot of difference it weighs a
whole lot of difference and when when
somebody else goes and does this record
or whenever something else happens and
we can we can share that moment cuz I'm
looking forward to that day
I like how how enthusiastic you are
about somebody else whether it's Dean or
somebody else going out and and and and
breaking your record or I wanted to be
Dean I want it to be followed him I'm a
huge fan I've absolutely loved the man
and I genuinely want to walk Jim the
trip unfold without having to be in the
painful position to feel like oh he's
there no I hope I can be a part of it
thank you thank you so if you want to
connect with Nick Nick better calm at
Nick butter run on Instagram and Twitter
and in terms of speaking the whole tour
is in the UK right now right you got the
whole schedule easy okay
we've got I mean another dozen countries
that we'd pop into anywhere but in the
UK is premier right but you'll update
that as that stuff continues along book
coming out at some point documentary
well I'll get stuff man so let me know
when all that stuff is ready and I'll
help push the word out thank you very
much appreciate you all right man
peace
[Music]